Bing.
Hey, George.
Can you hear me?
Yeah, hello.
Hey, how are you doing? I think you're outside or...
Yeah, I'm in, I'm in Texas. We just drove all night, so...
Ault.
Do you want to maybe any other time then? I think I'm not a good time because traveling, what do you suggest?
No.
Do you have something like this afternoon? You know, I can, this is my only call today, so like I can do anything later today or tonight for you, or...
Ohh.
For month or Tuesday, I think.
Tuesday, what time would you think would be good on Tuesday?
Um...
Can you do, like...
Best.
9am.
You're in East Coast or Pacific?
Um...
Mountain, but so then 11:00 East Coast.
Okay.
11 and 5.
Let me see the time.
Yeah, that will work for me. So I'll send you the new invite, you know, for Tuesday.
Oh, excellent.
Okay, perfect. Yeah, because I have some things I want to follow up on, so I appreciate that.
Yeah, I do have a few things which probably you asked that I have few pending update. So we'll connect on Tuesday then.
Sure.
Thanks, sir. Enjoy your weekend. Bye.
Sounds great. Have a good weekend.
Sage.
Singh.